Now the tricky part starts at n equals two and
I will construct this for you, you can take over
for three and four. For the one of the left
to have the sum equal to one, we stay at one,
which is we add up the value above and the two
on the left because there’s no three outcomes.
This guy over here is two, it’s the one above
and the two in the left, there’s nothing over
here but there is something over here.
This guy here is three, it’s a sum over the one
above and the two on the left gives us three.
We go down to two, which is a one above zero
and the two on the left, all the way back to one.
And this already looks very much like the
type distribution we talked about like this.